hello Internet welcome to film theory
where today we're taking the Lego
challenge nope not the one that ruins
your feet the one that ruins your
childhood now even though we're talking
about movies created from simple toys
you know the rules this isn't a toy it
kind of is no actually it's a highly
sophisticated interlocking brick system
fine even though we're talking about
movies created from highly sophisticated
interlocking brick systems I'm still not
gonna be pulling any punches I'm
bringing Lego out of the hypothetical
movie magic and into the real world of
Batman which is kind of weird since Lego
is real and Batman isn't so uh let me
clarify I'm bringing the fictional Lego
characters who canonically exist in the
real world but it's a fictional real
world out of their separate fictional
reality and into the reality based
fiction of Batman I think that makes
sense regardless despite us being
several levels of Inception down our
premise is surprisingly simple who is
stronger DC Batman or Lego Batman
literally since the day that I first saw
the lego movie which if you haven't seen
it is fantastic and heartwarming I have
asked myself this question and now
finally with the lego movie sequel
coming out it gives me the perfect
chance to finally answer this question
five years in the making and I get it I
know that you're thinking this is a
stupid question to dedicate an episode
and half a decade of waiting to cover of
course IRL Batman is gonna be stronger
he is a 200-pound ish man versus a three
gram Lego mini fig but what I want to
know is their strength relative to their
overall size lifting a 10 pound dumbbell
is nothing to a regular human but it
would be a feat of incredible strength
for a tiny Lego minifigure so we need to
measure each of them in their respective
universes as our real-life batman
contender i've chosen what i think is
the best version of batman that isn't
made of pressed and formed plastic the
Nolan Batman from The Dark Knight
trilogy don't add me or do at me
actually at Matt Matt GT love to have
you as a Twitter follower I tweet very
relatable things so we'll be gone with
his strength versus lego batman in our
big showdown today now when it comes to
measuring strength there are a lot of
different ways to do it so we're gonna
look at two main
actors 1 how much strength they exert
and 2 how much damage they can take
offense and defense so let's start
things off with a bang or rather kick
what are the best measures of Lego
Batman strength comes when he's at home
completely unbiased and with nothing but
his Ross trying then excellent reflexes
I have incredible reflexes yeah that's
what I just said Lego Batman and we see
those reflexes at work when he's caught
off guard by Alfred and kicks him into
the piano a piano that is completely
across the room it's safe to say that
he's not holding back anything in this
moment since he's acting purely on
instinct and I'm gonna assume it'd be
pretty hard for Christian Bale to match
the results of kicking someone his own
size halfway across a giant mansions
lounge so it would seem that Lego Batman
in this instance would definitely be
stronger than IRL Batman but to be sure
let's run some numbers when it comes to
calculating strength we can always rely
on our good old buddy Sir Isaac Newton
and a second law of motion which tells
us that force equals mass times
acceleration or to loyal theorists
who've been watching the show for a
while MA mass here is pretty
straightforward
since alfred is the thing that's moving
we need the mass of alfred and he has
the same mass as his identical
minifigure in the real world of two
point nine eight grams to figure out his
acceleration we need to use the
information that we see on screen going
through the movie frame by frame alfred
is airborne for 17 frames given that the
footage is 24 frames per second that
works out to a total air time of 0.7 0 8
3 3 3 3 seconds and the distance he's
traveling in that amount of time across
Batman's room appears to be 28 studs a
stud here not referring to Batman
put the bump on top of a Lego brick that
allows it to interlock with other bricks
which works out to be 22 point 2 6
centimeters in length so knowing the
distance and the time tells us that
Alfred is flying at a velocity of 31
point 4 to 6 centimeters per second so
now that we have Alfred's travel
velocity we can determine the
acceleration at the moment of impact and
by moment I really do mean moment
because going back to our frame-by-frame
footage Batman's foot connects with
Alfred's face for literally one frame a
mere point zero four one six six seconds
or 41 point six six milliseconds Lego
Batman was not lying about his
incredible reflexes that means that our
acceleration ends up being a whopping
seven hundred and fifty four point three
four centimeters per second squared or
heck forget centimeters that's big
enough to measure it in big boy units
that's seven point five four three four
meters per second squared so plug in all
that back into our good old SMAW
equation we're able to find out that
Lego Batman's kick is delivering point
zero two two four eight Newton's of
force or point zero zero five zero five
three seven pounds of force that may
seem like a small number and it is but
remember Lego Batman is a small guy
meaning that that's a pretty darn
impressive kick for someone of his size
and weight which means that if we're
gonna make a fair comparison between the
relative strengths of these two batman's
we need to measure it in terms of their
strength to weight ratio
how strong are they relative to how
heavy or fig they are so Lego Batman
strength to weight ratio when he makes
this kick is point zero zero 505 pounds
of force divided by point zero zero six
five seven pounds of weight or a
strength weight ratio of 0.769 that's
the equivalent of a 200-pound man
kicking with a hundred and fifty three
point eight pounds of force is that
actually impressive well to find out
let's compare him to Christian Bale man
now Christian Bale's Batman has plenty
of solid kicks throughout the Dark
Knight trilogy but all of them are a bit
hard to measure based on pure strength
alone there's just too many variables
and jump cuts around each of these fight
scenes that said this simple scene in
the Dark Knight Rises of him shattering
some bricks with a kick actually gives
us something solid to work with so how
much strength does it take to break some
bricks for that information we turn to
astronaut
old McNair's like a lot of astronauts
Ronald McNair was an MIT trained
physicist unlike a lot of astronauts he
was also a fifth degree black belt in
karate luckily for us those two
interests intersected and in one
demonstration of his brick shattering
strikes he actually had the force
recorded the bricks broke when he
exerted 675 pounds of force so using the
weight that Christian Bale was when he
filmed the Dark Knight trilogy of 210
pounds we're able to determine that IRL
Batman's strength to weight ratio is
three point two one four over four times
stronger than Lego Batman even when
you're talking a relative terms I am
very surprised by that result actually I
mean look at the difference of those two
cakes so just comparing the strength of
their kicks it seems like Lego Batman
loses out to big boy Christian Bale and
he's not just losing to Batman but most
normal people in this instance the
average person is able to leg press 1.8
to 2.2 times their own body weight
meaning that Lego Batman is less than
half the strength of a normal person you
sure you're not skipping leg day there
Batman but maybe this wasn't a fair
comparison
maybe the Lego characters lack of knees
holds them back when they try to kick so
let's see how the two batman stack up
against each other defensively of all
the abuse we see lego batman take
probably the most savage hit comes in
the lego batman movies opening action
scene when the Joker succeeds in ramming
Batman head-on with his car once again
we need to calculate force which means
getting mass and acceleration mass here
is easy the Joker is driving his
notorious lowrider Lego set number 709 o
6-1 now available for 39.99 where ever
lego sets are sold just in case you
forgot that all the lego movies are
ultimately an attempt to sell plastic
toys to kids having access to a
real-world version of the Lego vehicle
means that we can easily find its mass
0.63 kilograms or 1.38 pounds and yes
that does include the mass of the Joker
who is driving inside god I love doing
episodes where all this information just
exists because there are real-life
products for acceleration we followed a
similar procedure to the kicks measuring
distances and times using frame by frame
calculations ultimately winding up with
four
point six two to six meters per second
squared so now that we have mass and
acceleration we can calculate force out
to be two point nine one two Newtons or
point six five four pounds again that
looks like a small number but this time
when we adjust it for Batman's weight
things change drastically the ratio of
the force he's able to sustain versus
his weight is ninety nine point six five
three that's the equivalent of a
200-pound man getting smacked with
nineteen thousand nine hundred and
thirty pounds of force and yet here's a
Lego Batman just plugging it off that
Danish made plastic is built to last so
it's no surprise that a lego superhero
would have the same kind of durability
surprise surprise plastic can take a lot
more abuse than a human tissue or if so
we'd assume but to know for sure let's
check back in with our dark nights while
Lego Batman has to contend with Joker
and Sarang and Godzilla and Voldemort's
Nolan's Batman suffers defeat at the
hands of a much more mundane villain
well strategy to one-up them the way
that I do babe so but yes he does in the
Dark Knight trilogy there's only one
villain who succeeds in beating Batman
in hand-to-hand combat by giving him
injuries that take months to recover
from and his name ain't Joker
after all these years that voice is
still so weird to me anyway Batman's
body does break but how much punishment
is Batman's body actually taking you
know the drill by now MA analyze the
footage find the change in velocity
during the moment of impact multiply it
by Batman's canonical weight of 95
kilograms of 210 pounds and boom you got
it the force at the moment of impact
Batman's body's deceleration is seven
point four six meters per second squared
multiply that by as mass and you find
the impact of Bane's spine shattering
attack to be 708 Newton's or 159 pounds
of force which is not impressive not
impressive at all actually it's not even
enough to break a back now that might
seem weird at first that we had a
miscalculation somewhere along the line
but that's not actually true what it's
really telling us is that this scene was
filmed practically they use an actual
stun actor rather than using CG to make
the impact look more brutal and when
you're filming stuff for real you don't
want the actor to be subject to forces
that would actually break their back
Bane may not be pulling any punches in
the fictional world of Batman but
apparently Bane's actor Tom Hardy here
in the real world does probably for the
best so to be a bit more fair to the
live-action version of Batman we can
probably compare his body to that of a
typical human to get a more accurate
estimate for how much damage he could
take from a super villain like Bane
according to Holly Biden a neurosurgeon
at John Hopkins University School of
Medicine a spinal injury like the one
that we see in the movie would require
about 3,000 Newton's of force or about
670 four point four pounds of force it's
an impressive number to be sure but it's
a far cry from LEGO Batman's weight
adjusted 19900 30 pounds of force so
we're tied 1-1 in terms of durability
small plastic figurines blow humanity
out of the water but when it comes to
feats of kicking strength movable leg
joints are apparently super useful
except there's something else here
something that clearly decides this
Batman buff boy battle once and for all
you see punches and kicks aren't the
best way to determine Lego Batman's
actual strength him at his strongest is
actually showcased in something much
more mundane and commonplace in the lego
verse building in the original lego
movie they make a big deal out of the
fact that certain people in the LEGO
universe are master builders making
people like Batman and unikitty part of
this elite group Master Builders spend
years training themselves to clear their
minds enough and yet your mind is
already so prodigiously empty that there
is nothing in it to clear away in the
first place and it's this creative
ability to think outside the box or
without instructions that make master
builders so powerful in the Lego verse
except maybe there's another quality
than just pure creativity that matters
you see at the start of the movie when
Emmet is going to work at the
construction site it seems like there's
a lot of workers and infrastructure to
accomplish what should be relatively
simple tasks like connecting a 1 by 2
plate to another plate hammers cranes
hundreds of workers are involved in this
process and yet later on in the movie we
see the master builders doing things
like this in seconds with pieces that
are much larger than themselves it
really does take a feat of super
strength to whip those LEGO creations
together how much super strength glad
you asked because we're working with
Legos a widely used consumer product the
data is available to us and according to
a report measuring strength required to
build with Legos the bricks separation
on just 2 2 by 2 bricks measures out at
5.2 pounds that is over a thousand times
the force that we calculated for when
Lego Batman kicked Alfred across the
room that means that his strength to
weight ratio suddenly skyrockets it
comes out to 790 1.48
that's the equivalent of our 200 pound
Christian Bale exerting 158,000 295
pounds of force just imagine some dude
or heck Batman walking up to an adult
male African bush elephant the heaviest
land animal on the planet and just you
know lifting it up and then just
casually lifting up 11 more that is the
equivalent of what Lego Batman is doing
here every time he pries apart two Lego
bricks this means that not only does
Lego Batman handily beat out our Nolan
Batman but he does so to an
absurd degree not only is the Lego
Batman one of the best written and best
performed Batman in history but
strangely enough he's also the most
super-powered dear DC now that the news
is broken that your extended universe is
in need of yet another replacement for
the man in black I've got a little guy
who just might be the missing piece
you're looking for but hey everyone can
have a caped vigilante with a heart of
pure blackness protecting them in their
day to day life but you can get the next
best thing with our sponsor for today's
video
Noord VPN if you've ever been concerned
about hackers or identity theft of VPN
is your single best solution and Nord is
like the Batman of VPNs just like Batman
saw in Justices in the world and sought
out to correct him Nord was founded by a
group of childhood friends some would
call them a team of Superfriends looking
to fight against internet censorship and
intrusive surveillance into your online
life and they created it with a service
that offers unlimited bandwidth and
doubled data encryption for maximum
security online you know how Batman is
fast and stealthy well Nord bpms Chrome
browser is exactly the same it's super
lightweight it's easy to use and it
secures your browsing in seconds you
know how Batman just shows up places and
the villains are like oh no I didn't
think that you'd find me here
well Nords the same way with Android and
iOS apps that protect you even when
you're on a mobile device and just like
Batman travels the globe and his crime
busting adventures Nord VPN is also
international with thousands of servers
in 62 countries it's even able to work
in China and the Middle East Nord has
all the best features of Batman but is
also one step better than Batman because
unlike Batman Nord VPN has 24/7 customer
support Batman just works nights dark
nights but nice nonetheless that's not
all unlike the dark nights Batman where
he surveilled the entire city using
their cell phones Nord has zero data
logging what you do online with Nord is
and will always remain your own personal
business with no companies secretly
keeping track in the background
I mean sure at the end of The Dark
Knight Batman deleted all that
information he had but still Nord
doesn't keep it around in the first
place and right now for a limited time
you can get 75%
three year plan at Nord VPN dot-com /
film theory link is right there hovering
at the top of the description this
special offer makes your subscription
just $2.99 per month so you can browse
and shop online securely across all of
your devices it's also risk free with a
30-day money-back guarantee if they're
not Batman enough for your liking and
best of all you can use the code film
theory at checkout to get an extra month
of Nord protection for free so answer
the call join this Justice League dastan
line Justice League and have your online
life protected link is in the top line
of the description it's north VPN comm
slash film theory use film theory at
check out for an extra month thank you
guys so much for watching and I will see
you all next week